ما ان اطلق هذا الصاروخ البالستي العابر
للقارات حتى ادانته كل من كوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده واليابان التي قالت انه
سقط في منطقتها الاقتصاديه الخالصه ما
يعني انه قادر على ضرب اي مكان في البر
الرئيسي لامريكا
هو الاول منذ سبعه اسابيع حلقى لي 66
دقيقه بمسافه تصل الى 14 الف كيلو متر
اطلقته كوريا الشماليه في اطار تدريب
مفاجئ على حد تعبيرها وحينما عبرت الدول
الثلاثه عن موقفها مع تمديد مجموعه السبع
اكدت خبر الصاروخ الاخير
واعتبرت ان نجاح اختبارها دليل على قدرتها
على شن هجوم نووي مضاد وفتاك فالزعيم كيم
جونغ اون وافق على التدريب شخصيا وخططيا
بلا اشعار مسبق
وردا عليه ياتي سرب الطائرات هذا حيث اعلن
الجيش الكوري الجنوبي تنظيم مناورات جويه
مشتركه مع الولايات المتحده
شاركت فيها طائرات الشبح وقاذفه امريكيه
بعيده المدى واحده على الاقل وقال وزير
الدفاع الكوري الجنوبي ان المناورات سمحت
باظهار النشر الفوري لوسائل الردع
الامريكيه الموسعه في شبه الجزيره الكوريه
ما يدل على القوه الكاسحه للحلفاء
وما تزال مساله امتلاك كوريا الشماليه
لصاروخ باليسي عابر للقارات يعمل برؤوس
نوويه موضع نقاش خارجي اذ يقول بعض
الخبراء ان بيون جانج لم تتقن تقنيه
لحمايه الرؤوس الحربيه من الظروف القاسيه
لمعاوده دخول الغلاف الجوي